I want to talk a little bit about the
Republican Trump tax plan Speaker of the
House Paul Ryan was totally embarrassed
into deleting a tweet that he used to
tout the recent enactment of the new
Trump tax bills withholding tables you
might have noticed if you've already
received a paycheck in February that the
amount of withholding taxes might have
changed and you might be getting a
little more money in your paycheck you
might be getting a little less money in
your paycheck depending on your exact
tax bracket and income Paul Ryan decided
to take to Twitter and to tout a dollar
and 50 cent per week raise for a
secretary at a public high school in
Pennsylvania tweeting quote a secretary
at a public high school in Lancaster
Pennsylvania said she was pleasantly
surprised her pay went up a dollar fifty
a week she said that will more than
cover her Costco membership for the year
and the satirical Twitter account
lol GOP cleverly responded that Charles
a Koch brother in Wichita said that he
was pleasantly surprised that his pay
went up about 26 million dollars per
week as a result of the tax bill and
that this will allow him to buy several
more Paul Ryan's this led to Paul Ryan
deleting the tweet of course we still
have it to look at Paul Ryan has been
tweeting since February first
that he wants to hear from people on
Twitter now that the new federal
withholding tables went into effect he
wants people to check their paychecks
for their wage increases and tweet to
him how much more money they are getting
and apparently Paul Ryan decided that
the success story of a $6 per month
increase in someone's salary was worth
bragging about on Twitter and he's been
bragging Paul Ryan has been touting the
Donald Trump Republican tax bill as this
sort of tremendous windfall for the
American people for the middle class and
then he hand-picked the dollar and 50
cent
extra per week
an individual worker was making to point
out the major success that this tax bill
was and what I would really like to know
is how much Donald Trump is saving on a
weekly basis as a result of this tax
bill of course we don't know because
he's never released his taxes but I can
assure you that it's much more than one
dollar and fifty cents per week and this
is all a combination of out-of-touch and
depraved and what's depraved about it is
that when Paul Ryan touts a dollar fifty
per week as a victory for the middle
class it has the impact of sort of
conditioning the middle class that this
is the reality right even though the
rich are going to get hundreds of
thousands upon millions of dollars if
you're in the middle class you should be
happy with the dollar fifty a week in
your paycheck you should see that as a
major victory because what Republicans
are transmitting here is that this bill
was a major victory for the middle class
and that a dollar fifty a week is
representative of that victory this is a
few extra cents per hour for a 40-hour a
week workweek and you'd better be damn
happy about it if you're in the middle
class because this is what the
Republican Party sees as a victory for
you it's disgusting and it's great that
Paul Ryan was embarrassed into deleting
the tweet of course the leading the
tweet just puts more attention on it and
rightly so
and the bigger reminder I have for you
today is that Paul Ryan's seat is up for
grabs in November the primary in in
Wisconsin is August 14th the general
election is November 6th
there are options in Wisconsin if you're
not pleased with Paul Ryan and his
touting of a dollar and fifty cent a
week increase for a secretary Randy
Bryce is running against Paul Ryan
Google him very very interesting
candidate maybe send him a dollar 50 as
a sort of figurative show of financial
support we've got to vote these people
out because a dollar fifty a week as a
sign of victory for the middle class
when there are people saving huh
of thousands or millions of dollars in
taxes as a result of this tax bill it
can't be allowed it can't be allowed and
I know a lot of people on our subreddit
are following this story you can join
them and talk about Paul Ryan or
whatever else you want that's on the
program today at david pakman.com slash
our IDI di t we'll take a quick break
and be back with a lot more right after
this support for today's episode of the
david pakman show comes from hellofresh
hellofresh is a meal kit delivery
service that will shop plan and deliver
your favorite step-by-step recipes and
pre measured ingredients so all you have
to do is cook eat and enjoy
no time-consuming meal planning or
grocery shopping hello fresh makes it
really is easy to cook delicious
balanced dinners for under 10 bucks a
meal choose your delivery day and
everything is sent right to your door in
recyclable insulated packaging there's
three plans to choose from including
classic veggie and family something for
everyone plus there's lots of one-pot
recipes for seriously speedy cooking and
minimal cleanup look forward to your
hello fresh box delivery as the
highlight of your week because you'll
know dinner just got a lot easier
there's great balanced and satisfying
meals and it's also no waste I hate
having leftover ingredients and being
unsure what to do with them and before I
figure it out they've gone bad and I am
throwing food away that doesn't happen
with hellofresh you can get $30 off your
first week of hellofresh
by going to hellofresh comm and entering
the code Pakman 30 that's hellofresh
comm offer code PA que ma n30 for $30
off your first week of hellofresh